dans l'horreur allemande est donc en bas
c'est des animaux qui sont des ruminants
derrière adele responsable animation les
vedettes du jour lors du repas pour les
brebis de sologne
ce sont les visiteurs qui s'y colle même
pas peur véritable vitrine du patrimoine
naturel de sologne le domaine de siran
est très prisée par les familles qui ont
besoin plus que jamais de sortir
on a vraiment l'impression que des gens
recherchent la nature et puis surtout un
gros un grand bol d'air au milieu des
animaux et au milieu de cette belle
forêt sologne attend l'équipe
d'animation a été renforcée pour
accueillir au mieux les nombreux
visiteurs qui viennent assister aux
diverses activités
bref revenons maintenant à nos moutons
et intéressons-nous à leur toison
cette laine quand on la regarde d'un peu
plus près de quoi elle est constituée de
la toison à la pelote de laine il y a
beaucoup de choses à savoir
à découvrir avant de commencer à
tricoter sont plus de ses chaussettes
cette machine par exemple est très utile
pour garder la laine
une opération qui peut aussi se faire en
duo apparemment c'est un peu compliqué
petits et grands parfois sont mises à
contribution
le résultat a l'air satisfaisant bientôt
ces fibres de viendront fils et pelote
de laine grâce à ce fameux roux est
trouvé dans une ferme de sologne
conserver au domaine
merci à nous maintenant que ces
animations sont mises en place pour les
enfants et elles connaissent toujours
autant de succès pourquoi pour les
occuper là parce que chips non pour leur
faire découvrir d'autres choses
on est venu il ya quelques années déjà
avec les enfants et puis maintenant on
vient souvent avec nos petits enfants
quand ils sont en vacances on est mené
au mois de juillet pour l'animation
abeilles et puis là on est venu pour
l'animation moutons de sologne envies de
sorties en pleine nature
n'hésitez pas les autres sont très
accueillants
[Applaudissements]